bonjour et bienvenue pour ce premier
épisode de la série sur comment mieux
débattre et aujourd'hui on va se poser
la question d'une question importante je
pense c'est pourquoi débattre et j'ai
posé cette question sur twitter il ya
une norme direction donc c'est très très
sympa merci à dotant tous les gens de da
ce faire youtube scientifique tweetos
scientifique esprit critique et tout ça
donc merci pour vos réponses vous invite
à aller voir si vous voulez avoir les
réactions des uns et des autres et donc
les réponses à cette question des uns et
des autres je vais soulever quelques
réponses qui est un petit peu émergé il
ya l'idée de s'exprimer qui est pas mal
sorti
donc on peut d pouvoir débattre parce
qu'on a des idées à exprimer il ya aussi
l'idée de mieux penser je pense que
c'est des idées intéressantes c'est de
mieux penser en débattant et c'est
quelque chose que je fais énormément à
foix débattre pour m'exprimer aussi
débattre pour mieux penser je suis pas
sûr que ce soit des bons des bonnes
raisons de débattre mais c'est des
raisons de débattre il ya cette idée
aussi de clarifier ses propos c'est
quelque chose que je fais énormément je
débats pas mal pour essayer de mieux
parler des différents sujets notamment
sur la question de la morale des ia
avant je pars et démoralisé a maintenant
j'essaie de parler plus de rendre les ja
bénéfique mais je pense que ça
s'améliore et sa clarifier un peu plus
propos est aussi cette idée d'acquérir
de l'information dont on débat pour
avoir des nouvelles de donner des
informations qu'on connaissait pas avant
de les battre il ya aussi cette idée de
comprendre l'autre se trouve ça
intéressant on débat pour avoir des
retours de l'autre et du coup pour
comprendre l'autre et puis aussi cette
idée de débattre pour le plaisir qui est
pas mal sorti
j'ajouterai un peu cette liste acquérir
des arguments scénario l'autre apte et
des arguments intéressants à nous
proposer et qui vont peut-être même dans
l'autre sens et du coup c'est
intéressant de les collecter et ça c'est
un peu les réponses qui sont plus sortis
sur twitter et ça m'a frappé quand
mettant finalement d'hésiter des raisons
assez égoïste n'hésites pas que les ceux
qui me suivent sur twitter sont des gens
égoïstes en fait valoir
mais sam ça s'annonce vraiment au moins
égocentrique les raisons qui sont donnés
de débattre c'est pour nous
tout nous mêmes alors c'est sans doute
dû à la manière dont j'ai posé le truc
ça pas mal insisté sur ce que je fais
mal dans un débat du coup ça donne
l'impression que je pense beaucoup à moi
dans un débat et c'est sans doute mais
je pense que ce serait mieux si on se
réfléchit c'est un fait que lorsqu'on
débat on débat avec d'autres gens et que
du coup ces autres gens sont aussi
importants dans le débat et finalement
si on débat c'est autant ça devrait être
en tout cas au moins autant pour eux
voire peut-être davantage pour eux que
pour nous et ça ça m'amène à d'autres
raisons de débattre notamment le fait de
vouloir convaincre l'autre je pense que
c'est une raison ouais un peu tabou ou
presque il ya un petit peu un tabou
derrière idée de jeu débat pourquoi
pratique c'est vraiment en tout cas
lucas et moi en pratique l'objectif
vraiment que j'essaie de me donner sur
lequel on insistera énormément c'est que
je joue tout cas j'essaie de faire en
sorte que l'objectif de mes débat avec
j'essaie de me rappeler que l'objectif
de débats peut-être que ça ne devrait
plus être le fait de dan et l'autre à
réfléchir et en fait taire ses parts
égales sont tout à fait ça en pratique
et notamment sur twitter ou sur youtube
où je prépare dans les actions en fait
je n'ai pas pas juste pour moi et pour
l'autre personne avec qui je déballe
tout est possible pour tous pour tout le
public
on a des débats souvent public et quand
le debug public c'est je pense
extrêmement important de réfléchir au
public qu'on peut affecter de façon
négative parfois clash un petit peu
mauvaise en exagérant les choses on peut
avoir un effet très négatif sur le
public
je pense que c'est important d'avoir le
public en tête et voir de faire du
public
la priorité donc ça peut être pour le
convaincre par exemple tu arrives to
changement climatique chose de très
important mais ça peut être aussi à
ramener le public à mieux réfléchir et
j'aurais tendance à dire que bien
souvent c'est l'objectif que j'aimerais
avoir onze ans d'âge
un débat il a certainement remarqué très
intéressante qui faisait la remarque
en fait il y a
deux façons d'interpréter à la question
pourquoi débattre on peut dire que
pourquoi débattre c'est une question
descriptif c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on
débat en pratique pourquoi est ce que je
le débat d'ailleurs c'est un peu comme
ça que j'avais tourné à la question je
les pose et impôts la communauté temps
et éthiques
et puis à l'autre question pourquoi est
ce qu'on devra débattre qu'est ce
qu'elle est bonne raison de débattre
qu'on n'a pas forcément en tête qu'on
engage en débat c'est vraiment les
questions à peut-être plus normatif
qu'est-ce que qu'elle soit réelle et
bonne raison de débattre et je pense que
c'est important d'avoir en tête que ces
deux objectifs sont généralement pas s'y
aligner que ça nous a tendance à engager
pour les débats pour des raisons qui ne
sont pas les raisons qui devraient avoir
du coup ça nous amène à avoir un dé
certains réflexions et débats qui sont
pas forcément ceux qu'on devrait avoir
si on réfléchit davantage aux objectifs
que l'on a ou qu'on devrait avoir
au moment d'engager des débats donc en
particulier les raisons pour lesquelles
on débarque en pratique il ya pas mal de
trucs qui se sont en fait mauvais comme
par exemple l'idée de on débat pour
combattre l'autre pour le ter voir pour
lui nuire voire le décrédibiliser alors
ça peut être un moyen intéressant pour
arriver à une autre fin mais c'est assez
bizarre d'enfer l'objectif si votre
objectif c'est vraiment ça m'a dit à vos
débats vous probablement dégénéré ils
vont pas forcément être très utiles ils
vont être même très probablement très
néfaste pour l'autre et pour le public
peut-être que pour vous ça me fera
plaisir et peut-être que pour les gens
qui me supportent pour ce faire ça ne
sera pas mal il ya un côté assez a assez
wigan finalement danser dans ces débats
a un côté assez clan on a tendance à
engager des débats pour soutenir notre
camp a typiquement sa joie énorme dans
l'elite il hérite 8 là il ya vraiment ce
côté on rit tuit tour gens du même côté
parce que c'est le truc c'est de trucs
de l'autre camp
c'est pas forcément un bon objectif
c'est pas forcément une bonne manière si
on se pense à d'autres objectifs du
développement pourrait être plus
important de casser des objectifs que
j'aurais tendance pousse à vouloir
vouloir comme par exemple le fait de
faire mieux réfléchir à la fois le camp
opposé pour l'amener ensuite à mieux
penser à penser autre chose différemment
que juste si possible et voir fait en
sorte que l'autre veille davantage
certaines choses et fassent telle ou
telle action
si on est dans cette perspective on se
rend compte que ce côté très hooligans
très près la guérite 8 les trucs un peu
cassant les trucs un peu un peu un peu
hooligans en tout clash
finalement c'est sans doute très très
néfaste à cet objectif
et puis l'autre raison pour laquelle on
débat beaucoup en pratique des raisons
descriptif pour lesquels on débat qui ne
sont en fait une très mauvaise façon de
débattre mais bon en pratique je le fais
beaucoup parce que je n'arrive pas à
penser à mes objectifs que je devrais
avoir et voyez ce que je veux c'est que
voudrait vouloir est ce que je vais pas
forcément ce que je voudrais vouloir est
ce que je veux parfois dans un débat
s'est montré par exemple que voyager une
autorité g j'ai une expertise où je suis
quelqu'un de bien il ya pas mal cette
idée de l'auto promotion parlera pas mal
de sa c2 signalling et parfois ccg et
quand il ya un débat un peu frustrant
mais j'ai quand même envie de taper du
poing sur le dos rond désormais comme
suit mathématicien sais pas trop quoi
pour essayer d'asseoir une autorité et
parfois ça aide c'est parfois c'est une
très bonne stratégie pour être amené à
mes fins qui sont peut-être plus faire
réfléchir
l'autre par exemple mais souvent en fait
c'est des choses qui sont assez néfaste
à mes objectifs
tous les objectifs que j'aimerais avoir
donc tout ça ça m'amène un peu amer
acide de deux places et où tous ces
différents objectifs sur un axe par
exemple ex descriptif normatif donc des
scripts fait ce qu'on fait en pratique
et normatif c'est ce qu'on aimerait
faire et peu ces différents objectifs
sont quelque part sur ces axes et ce qui
est dommage c'est qu'ils sont un peu de
10 juin généralement en tout cas pour
moi ils sont malheureusement assez 10
juin
souvent j'essaie de faire en sorte que
ça change et je pense que c'est
important de travailler sur un fait en
sorte que ça change
notamment il fait en sorte que les
raisons pour laquelle j'ai débat en
pratique vraiment d'importance diminuent
voire disparaissent et que les raisons
pour lesquelles je devrais débattre se
rapproche du côté descriptif et du coup
soient les raisons en tant que possible
pour lesquelles je débats en pratique ça
sera un petit peu l'idéal essaie
d'amener le côté normatif vers le haut
que vers le descriptif mais comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile france est un
autre axe qui est intéressant pour un
peu classe et ses différentes
ces différentes raisons de débattre
c'est là que ce soit selon as que
nécessaire devant passer par un débat où
est ce qu'il existe des alternatives et
par exemple pour le fait de s'exprimer
si votre but est d'exprimer sans sida
c'est à dire avoir quelque chose en vous
et le sortir l'année dehors c'est
peut-être pas forcément bonne idée de se
débattre c'est pas parce que quelque
chose doit être dit qui doit être
entendu et ça c'est quelque chose que tu
en tant que mathématicien ça m'arrive
tout le temps parce que il ya beaucoup
de choses que j'ai besoin d'exprimer
parce que ça aide énormément à clarifier
mes idées mais voilà du brouillon de
match il faut pas laisser j'ai pas envie
qu'il soit lu en plus et du coup il ya
cette façon quand même de s'exprimer
sans engager un débat qui est d'utiliser
un brouillon et c'est quelque chose que
j'essaie de faire de plus en plus pour
des trucs et sociaux notamment
mais a parfois j'ai une envie
d'expression sur un sujet chaud et voilà
je commence à écrire intuit puis je me
rends compte qu'en fait si j'écris je
lâche ce tweet fait savoir des
conséquences assez néfaste parce que la
raison pour laquelle j'écris tout de
suite c'est pour m'exprimer pas pour
amener les gens à mieux réfléchir et
donc à ce moment là j'essaie de file
vers un bouillon sur un ordinateur et
d'exprimer mes idées comme brouillon
puis ensuite fichiers restauration d'un
ordinateur
il sera pas lui et je pense que c'est
une bonne façon de réfléchir au fait que
voilà il ya des objectifs qu'on se donne
dans les débats mais bien souvent ils
sont résolus par d'autres alternatives
qui ont des conséquences vraiment bien
moins néfaste que le fait de débattre à
ces sujets l'autre exemple typiquement
de cela c'est le fait d'expliquer des
arguments complexe on peut faire ça on
débat
mais c'est très difficile et c'est très
efficace et ça va pas très bien marché
sont souvent parce qu'on est interrompue
c'est un autre sujet on essaie de
revenir ça va être compliqué et du coup
pour expliquer des idées complexes
débattre et je consigne très mauvaise
idée
présidée pour expliquer les idées de
complexe pour vous expliquer je vois le
fonctionnement des intelligences
artificielles pourquoi est ce que la
sûreté les intelligences artificielles a
été un sujet très important j'ai pas
engager un débat
j'ai fait une série de vidéos youtube je
pense que c'est un fake s'intéresse en
fait qu'à ça m'arrive souvent que les
gens viennent me voir et me disent ah
par rapport à ça je suis pas mal
réfléchi j'ai pas mal d'idées
comment je fais pour que les envoyer bas
surtout de langage pour un débat et puis
aussi voilà twitter les commentaires
youtube sont pas forcément la meilleure
façon d'y arriver dès qu'il ya des gens
se plaignent que twitter est l'étude
sont trop courts moi dès qu'il ya des
trucs long des pavés des frais de
twitter j'ai tendance à ne pas les lire
parce que c'est juste que l'on est
souvent c'est pas toujours intéressant
c'est pas toujours bien travaillé et je
pense que c'est très important de
travailler à la manière de communiquer
vos idées compliquer la meilleure façon
d'y arriver c'est de les rendre aussi
agréable à suivre que possible pour la
plupart des gens et améliorer de manière
d'y arriver c'est pas en débattant ya
pas mal l'alternative youtube où tous
les podcasts typiquement je pense que
c'est une très très bonne alternative à
ce qu'il y ait des idées compliqué a
expliqué mme à lancer votre chaîne
youtube vous lancez votre podcast et si
c'est bien foutu semble que je
regarderai donc là c'est penser un petit
peu mon jeu j'ai un peut on arrêter là
mais voilà j'espère que cette réflexion
vous avez un petit peu intéressés et
surtout on peut poser un peu la question
mais tarde maintenant pourquoi est ce
que j'ai essayé d'engager un débat sur
pourquoi débattre
vraiment je pense assez d'avoir fait ça
c'est pas mal réfléchi et du coup j'ai
ainsi pas même le contrôle mais le deal
et c'était vraiment que je pense qu'il
ya vraiment un besoin de mieux réfléchir
à pourquoi débattre et que beaucoup de
gens qui débattent devraient mieux
réfléchir donc y'a vraiment c'est
positif dernier les gens à réfléchir
mais aussi de les convaincre que c'est
super important de réfléchir à comment
mieux débattre et c'est vraiment quelque
chose que j'aimerais avoir beaucoup plus
sur twitter notamment mais un peu
partout cet encouragement à mieux
débattre
il peut y arriver bah c'est intéressant
de se poser régulièrement la question
mais pourquoi est-ce que j'ai débat
et il ya plein d'autres réflexes à avoir
ensuite on peut en déduire de notre
réflexion sur pourquoi débattre et on y
viendra dans cette série mais c'est un
super important d'essayer d'amener tout
le monde ici tout ce qui regarde cette
vidéo
et puis aussi vos amis en partageant
cette vidéo ou en leur parlant de juste
cette question pourquoi débattre
je pense que c'est super important de
diffuser cette réflexion sur pourquoi
débattre
donc voilà j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à engager des
débats dans les commentaires ou en
réaction à cette vidéo sur twitter ou
sur facebook
mais n'oubliez pas ce faisant de poser
la question de pourquoi est ce que vous
faites ça pourquoi est-ce que vous
engager le débat et surtout de comment
faire pour que ce débat atteignent les
objectifs que vous vous êtes fixé